yeah so i do want to talk about kung fu
but i do want to get your thoughts over
the last few days because i know
you've been someone who's been very
vocal uh speaking out about the attacks
on the asian community and obviously the
shootings
in georgia have finally brought the
conversation to the forefront
how are you feeling over the past 48
hours
uh you know as i said in the beginning
when i first heard the no
news it was heartbreaking yeah
that you know eight of um
and and six asian women were massacred
it really hurt me it broke my heart yeah
then i got angry
then i tried to look for solutions and
and to talk about it
to to really again you know bring
awareness i i don't see
and and i've said this before i don't
really know what the immediate fixes are
because we've tried everything
we've we've you know i mean there had
been no coverage about the
anti-asian hate crimes and then there
were
coverage right by news media
about by our president all the way to
the
senate and the you know the house of
representatives
um and it continues so i don't know what
the answer is
every day i read something it's very
difficult very difficult
in fact it affects my psyche right i
mean when i go for a walk i want to make
sure the sun's behind me and my shadow
is cast in front i know i want to know
what's behind me
well let's just give me chills out
having this thing like that like yeah
just
a crazy mentality do you feel any hope
over the past couple days because more
people
are talking about it after such a
horrific tragedy like this
yes i i feel that we do have a lo a
sense of the long-term solution which
takes time
right conversations one education is
another uh
presenting you know truthful images you
know to the audience is
for what we do is important because
we have the opportunity to come into
your living room and
to your your movie theaters and and and
so that
you can see you know a truthful
three-dimensional
characters that that you it may ring
you know it triggers something in you
yeah you know so that you can see
that that you know we are of one yeah
i know it's probably something difficult
for you to talk about but i think it's
important for people to hear like i know
you had your own experience
towards the beginning of covet of of
racism right
yeah i was it was very early and i think
it was only about
maybe even like a few days or a week in
in and when we found out
when when uh they were talking about
finding this virus you know that
happened in wuhan china somewhere
and i was home uh going to
to whole foods to get some provisions
and uh in pasadena i drove
there and a car slowed down and started
rolling up
and i said wow how could he courteous if
this
man let me walk but it wasn't the case
he stopped in front of me
wrote down his window and looked at me
and said you should be quarantined
and talk off wow
wow i mean out of the blue
oh what hit me yeah and that's the thing
i mean
yeah yeah hopefully in this time i mean
yeah we're hearing more of these stories
so hopefully
people become more aware of it just so
disturbing so i can't imagine
yeah what you're going through but yeah
i like what you said about um
kung fu that you think it's part of the
solution you want to explain that in a
bit
well you know you're talking about the
long-term solution we have with the
opportunity to come into your living
room to
present to you a realistic portrayal of
an
asian-american family you know that
involves you know immigrant parents and
american children
the hopes and dreams of what we do and
what we say
and you will see similarities in us in
you
yeah family strides and you know
every family that have it and then you
will see
our differences which i believe you will
embrace
because all of us have something to
offer
and that's one part of our story and the
other part of it
is our action part the martial arts
that is a a proven you know that crosses
barrier barriers that the fact that
we're
able to bring you entertainment
excitement
action you know fun that
is a an important bridge
you know for because then you're already
a willing partner
yeah seeing us yeah so i think it's easy
to deliver
any kind of message or talk
in that manner because you're already
willing to be there to see us
and share this with us so that is
something
what we have we have two things that are
happening in this show
that i'm so excited about one martial
arts
two family aspect of it
those are the things that that i i'm you
know really excited about and that we
can
at least have the opportunity to
change the perception how you view us
yeah you know did you watch yeah
did you watch the original with david
carradine did you check it out at all i
did because i was i thought i mean
originally i thought i was the only one
that was old enough to see it in real
time
but that was wrong no screen wife kang
also saw it in real time
i was i was surprised that's the damn
really you did too
okay what did you think of it she didn't
look old enough man come on she looks
like
anyway so i did see the original in real
time
so it was fascinating man you know and i
and and i like what we're doing with it
yeah yeah does it feel like does it feel
very different from that original or
what are the differences with it
yes or no because in the wawa west
yes said in real you know present day
san francisco
so just the locale itself
will be will be very different and but
it doesn't really stray from that kind
of theme about
our hero in our case a heroine you know
who
really raised the ship and trying to
search out injustice everywhere to uh
to to help the people who are helpless
yeah
that's a continuing theme right and and
our advantages therefore we do get you
get a chance to see your family
and unfortunately ken was by himself
right
man the poor guy he's like going out
there in the wild west all by himself
we have we have a family we have help so
we're
that's that's like you know you know
that's us yeah you know we uh
we're okay now but i i think also you
know the the original
one thing that that i felt that was
really powerful
was that you know it was the only tv
show that asian american actors or asian
actors were had an opportunity to be
seen
right and if you if you know show i mean
you know it's
literally a who's who of all the
asian-american actors of the time yeah
everybody you know you don't buy key
look
you know marco uh
james shigeta mean yeah but you know
who happens to be canadian i think yeah
yeah
yeah well that's the other thing i found
it so interesting that i mean you just
did mulan
and now you're doing this so you're
playing the father of these you know
female wars so what's it like to be part
of obviously mulan was
the live-action version of this and this
is really imagining with the female lead
so what's like being part of these
stories with these female characters
i think that's the book end right there
yeah bulan
i mean i think nick is the reincarnation
of mulan
yeah i think they are both woman
warriors
they are smart they
can fight they're beautiful
they have strong father figures in their
lives
so a very supportive dad a dad that
recognizes the value
because in mulan there's a line where my
character says i am blessed
with daughters yeah that says a lot
he didn't say i have two daughters he
said i'm blessed with two daughters
right so that's what we want to carry
forward in present day
in nicki because nikki is destined
destined for greatness
yeah i know she sees that yeah yeah i
noticed in your um
instagram bio you have hollywood's
favorite asian dad like is that
something you embrace
do you embrace that yeah absolutely i
mean kind of a joke for me because i
just do so many of them right
but i tell you i have an all-star team
of girls man i'm telling you my
daughters are
just amazing so so and i'm telling you
nikki is uh is really somebody
this character embodies everything
that i like to see you know the strength
the intelligence you know the care
you know the the kind of a sense of
justice
that is so powerful and we need because
look what happened i mean we've you know
our asian women have been
really demonized and stereotypically
sexualized and all of these things that
we need to correct
and i think we could find that in nikki
to change that perception
yeah with others and like what you're
saying about kung fu like is that
something you look at with roles like
beyond just looking at a script
do you look at what am i putting out
there what asian representation am i
putting out there with this are you very
conscious of that
100 percent you see you yeah you know
what's up
because you know this stuff's forever
man you can't go anywhere you know
after i'm long and gone they're going to
still see it
hey man this dude did this thing you
know back in the day boy
what else think of that is you know i'm
saying you can't you can't get away with
this stuff and then i'll be able to say
oh wow you know he did this like you
know back in the day
man it was pretty cool okay yeah so
really i mean yes that's in
my country i totally am aware of that
and i want to make sure that whatever it
is that i'm passing on
you know is something of value at least
something
you know right no matter how big or
small and and that that's something i
i'm
totally consciously uh very aware you
know what
is that is that the kind of advice you
have for younger actors
asian actors specifically yeah i think
so i i mean personally i
i think i think you know for for all
actors of color should be very
discriminate about what they do
because i think it develops you know
your sensibility
it develops you what you know when you
read a script you know
you know in your heart of hearts you
know whether or not that rings true or
not
yeah i think it's important i mean if it
doesn't then then the question to you
is that can you affect it
can you walk into a room and say you
know what i can make this a
three-dimensional character
in your mind okay and that begins by
questioning
by and and and i'm telling well
you can't walk into a room anymore oh my
gosh
sorry excuse the language yes i'm sorry
i just realized that it's all zoomed now
it's true
right is that right got to walk into
your mental room i guess
yes yes i could say oh my god you can't
walk into a room anymore
but yes i mean i think i think you
really want to
uh um give yourself that opportunity
you know if you think that that is
something that you can you know help
by all means help it and then if
if you can and by at the end of the day
at the end of that zoom meeting and you
feel that you've done
all your best to make that a
three-dimensional character and an
honest truthful character and if that
doesn't happen then you can say thank
you for the opportunity and you can just
leave and
click off and put that little button say
leave right
it's that easy yeah i'm telling you so
really
i think you can you know take uh
action and empower yourself give
yourself that opportunity
you know i mean if you read something
you say oh man there's no way
then by all means just uh saying thank
you yeah
don't go and you've been someone who's
very uh outspoken about
the lack of you know nominations at
awards so so what do you think of
steven young finally like long overdue
breaking that best actor barry being the
first asian american to get the best
actor nomination
i'm exhausted i'm telling you
man i tell you it's like a double time
company
i'll have a new day and really just the
attention that was paid by
you know these wonderful pieces of work
with with uh
chloe zoe and and stephen and
uh yj i mean our grandma oh my god she
is
amazing oh yeah i tell you
you know it really is something that
i found it perplexing you know that
didn't happen
before because you look at some of the
really beautiful films that were done
in the past and and they get every
other you know recognition and accolade
but never the acting
which i find kind of peculiar
and uh you know since now i'm the newly
minted member of the academy
i i see some of it because it's just so
much material
right you really need to bring attention
the community plays a big part
right if the community start to learn
that we need to support
these projects out there that because
it's just too much to remember
right you know and these in the members
all over the world
we're not just talking about they
they're you know everybody's in one room
everybody's scattered all over the world
you really need to get the message
out you know please you know enjoy
enjoy this film enjoy this work you know
uh
pay it you know take a look at it you
know give it give us you know your
attention
because i'm telling you you know how
many films i viewed in the last two
two months oh my god yeah my head is
spinning
and i'm working on top of it because
it's right close to 2 000 films
right wow yeah well i do think miari
should win best picture i think it's
amazing
uh-huh i think yeah i think um
you know it's out there now yeah exactly
so
so now it's up to the members and
hopefully you know that all the powers
that be continues to bring attention
keep it fresh keep it in the front of
the mind as opposed to
someone's the back of the mind right now
i mean i don't
i don't think you're going to struggle
to have eyeballs on kung fu but
how would you sell people what is your
what is your cheese for kung fu
sell it to me have fun you mean we're
gonna you're gonna enjoy us
i'm telling you we're a goofy bunch